في تطورات التوتر بمضيق تايوان قالت وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه انها تعقبت 35 طائره
عسكريه صينيه في محيط تايوان بدورها قالت
وكاله رايترز ان الصين تخطط لفرض منطقه
حظر طيران شمال تايوان بين السادس عشر
والثامن عشر من ابريل الجاري وزاره الدفاع
تايوانيه ردت بالقول ان منطقه حظر الطيران
التي
تتحدثين تقع على بعد 85 ميلا بحريا شمال
تايوان
ومن جانبها اكلت قياده المسرح الشرقي في
الجيش الصيني ان المناورات العسكريه التي
استمرت ثلاثه ايام اختبرت قدرات البحريه
الصينيه القتاليه
وكشف الجيش الصيني هو انه اختبر تكتيكات
جديده خلال المناورات مؤكدا ان سفنه
الحرب تواصل تدريبات قتاليه حول تايوان
وفي بذور ذلك ذكرت وكاله الانباء
التايوانيه ان 25 مقاولا امريكيا سيزورون
الجزيره الشهر المقبل لبحث خطط انتاج
مشترك للمسيرات والذخيره